hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Wario's
another five nights at Freddy's fan-made
game that's pretty self-explanatory I
don't really need to say much and I know
this isn't gonna go well for me because
I'm playing with a mouse on a couch and
as you know five nights at Freddy's gave
me my very badly there once was a man
named Wario who worked along with a
friend of his on Wario Zone fast food
factory because they have factories one
day however the two women went missing
and they were never found
oh well so sad since that day the
factory has been closed due to people
thinking the factory was cursed screw
all their jobs go home curses seven
years later the government decided to
reopen the factory and start the
production again one man had gotten the
job as guard during the night okay maybe
those jobs weren't that important after
all okay all right then
[Music]
thanks gray oh boy
I'm so happy that I'm here in this world
of terror
now it's pretty much whoa whoa whoa whoa
I saw you I see you there Wario oh no
you and your brother went missing long
ago you were disinvited from the Smash
Brothers party and you're seeking your
revenge as far as I know maybe he wasn't
a pretty tubes included I don't know I
haven't played the new one hmm where's
waluigi why all the weed you was always
my favorite like i mean if you have to
have a favor - Wario and Waluigi I
always liked wallet we do more I
especially liked him in Super Mario
Strikers because he had that ability to
wall off himself as he just takes off 5
star level kick towards the goal many
people probably have no idea what I'm
talking about but those that played
Super Mario Strikers as much as I did it
probably like yeah what all the weeds
you would do shouldn't let's I was
playing him and that's how you have it
Johnny way gotta survive six hours Oh
God oh it doesn't automatically turn off
the light okay that's different for five
nights at freddys I mean with any of
these five nights at Freddy's fan games
it's gonna be some give-and-take between
Oh between the original formula and then
it's gonna be a pretty close emulation
although I don't think I'm gonna be
playing through all five nights of this
game I am gonna get probably as far as I
can in one session
I mean am i all alone that window there
reminds me of that would know there okay
I'm probably not gonna die both in the
game in in real life but just in case I
all we knew - not outside my door is he
that dickbag it's so slow such a tiny
itty-bitty distance and yet it's so slow
going in between them I don't like it it
reminds me too much of the original oh
hey well you're both here while Luigi
your arms got a lot longer and gangly er
so what happens if I just stare at you
hmm
oh yeah I use camera battery I forgot
damn this damning thing down this damn
you damn all of you for making me Oh
Wario's gone I see you are you there
what's that sound
I mean waluigi is about to claw my eyes
out with his dangly arms baby boar
you'll get all the way back oh oh hey it
just looks like a dopey person Stefon
all over the place I don't know if I
should be that worried but then again
I've always thought that Wario and
Waluigi were awfully shifty looking
don't trust them much hmm it's only 2:00
a.m. goddamn I don't know there's gonna
be slower or faster than the original
five nights at Freddy's all I know is
that I thought I got the poop scared out
of me
I'm so terrified or something what's the
back there get they make up their mind
come at me bro
come on me I'm all alone here in the
grumper office I won't your beer much
longer my internet is scheduled but I'm
here alone according late at night
I am unexposed oh god don't kill me
please
kill me while to win you still there
god damn you oh you're you're nowhere
close to me stop even trying to be scary
don't even bother
dhadak it's not noises this time I'm
feeling things come on do something or
don't
he's importance preferable I don't have
one preference or another I don't know
where you bastards are now I don't know
if I'm like not gonna see him out of the
corner my hair or something or if
they're coming after my or if I'm
honored die pretty good oh they're over
there they're having a party by
themselves they're scared they're more
scared of me now I am of them was like
most of my fans are folk scared to meet
her and they heard I did it so I I beat
the first night I'm gonna keep playing
because I didn't actually get scared at
all and I know that's what you guys want
to see you my eyes want to see me over
there
what do you mean case I feel like it you
know something Bad's happening you're
shifty phone guy this guy's the purple
guy from five nights at Freddy's
we're crop you want to run that by me
again skipper
you wanna run that by me again yeah they
only had ghost sightings here so they
just decided not to blow the up
and just continue making delicious
fast-food burgers whoa what the is
with Luigi Luigi he's a ghost I thought
he was hanging at first I thought he was
being weighed down by his gigantic nose
but what what okay hi it's like the
intro screen from Mario 64 someone
dragged his face just a little too much
there Luigi you gonna be all right
Luigi Luigi bro bro bro Sethe Bravo
again these no oh no nothing again these
noises aren't exactly inviting for me I
don't know how often I need to check
hello your clothes I smell bad Freddy
it's always good when my jokes gets
self-referential
I always get self-referential when I get
slightly panicked no one knows what
reference I'm doing it Sims for you oh
hey how's it going they're looking real
strong there I didn't know what happened
to the weeds here why he's in on this
deal he shouldn't be here none of them
should be here they should just stay
dead oh hey you're really close to me
wait I should be concerned about that
that's a bad thing what are you gonna do
I think I wasn't told that you were
gonna be here your big freaking sibling
knows ok it was a period nothing
happening for a while there how am I
gonna know if he's gone oh boy oh my
turn that off I'm gonna need to waste
power here is he gone Oh God
hi ok I'm just gonna leave that closed
Luigi and his big nose can go away I'll
be fine just here what do I do
hey that door wasn't open before you
want to close it on the way out - go
yourself Phil huh
was that something I heard a noise you
didn't do nothing
oh I am trapped but it's almost 6:00 a
guy did something finally happened
oh man until I die that's what happened
even though I'm all by myself this way
[Music]
okay it's like a weights during the
phone call so it doesn't expect you to
go out there and go get em go get em
slugger just get ready I'm gonna talk
but you're gonna die
no no just all of a sudden activated and
they became very active I expect to die
in this round oh I think that'll be
enough for me because I actually do not
like being alone in this room and the
grump room all by myself by myself as
confident as my demeanor is I'm actually
quite perturbed in the goddamn windows I
know I'm gonna turn around it was gonna
be Luigi's bow hey what the hell you're
huge what Oh Oh what is he even going on
here I can't click correctly it's
bugging me I can't get two things that I
need to get to and I know it's gonna
kill Mike okay just gotta get through
the night it's only nine three hey and
five nights at Freddy's 2 night 3 only
took me an hour to beat hey this one's
gonna be easier
[Music]
oh hey hey it's a party in my office
hey okay bye all right so I guess I'm on
the left what am I gonna do about it I
don't know what he's gone makes my life
a bit easier I guess I know if he's oh
he's still there yes he is he's in fact
still there okay he's gone yay good I
guess
yay okay so I got away for the auditory
cues which are really gonna save my butt
I guess whoa whoa where is that that's a
fusion from Cabot - your clothes are
those stink lines are just stray hairs
okay he's a little more camera-shy than
he was prior right so apparently peach
and Mario are in here and then some
douchebag who lured these poor
unsuspecting members of the Mushroom
Kingdom
high-ranking members mind you and then
murdered them and stuff them into their
own bodies Oh
Oh dick with me came did you do
Oh hey open the door a little bit bye
goddamn that's gonna kill me because I
can't click correctly oh hey how's it
going Princess Pea okay well there's
very definitive auditory things
happening when they come and go oh I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die
this is why I die I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead just do it
already
okay do I have to put up the thing son
of a so anyway that was five
nights at Wario's I don't plan on
playing the full game unless they do it
on like a live stream or something in
the future but you can find out more
about the story because I believe all
five nights and maybe some secrets are
available for you in the link in the
description below thanks again everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]